[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 19 janvier le
chef de la diplomatie américaine
poursuit sa tournée consacrée à la crise
ukrainienne depuis kiev anthony blinken
a demandé à vladimir poutine de choisir
la voie pacifique
un appel lancé à deux jours de sa
rencontre à genève avec son homologue
russe sergueï lavrov
moscou affirme de son côté privilégié
une résolution diplomatique la russie
qui regrette l' enveloppe débloquée par
washington en faveur de kiev une aide
sécuritaire de 200 millions $ jugée
comme une menace imminente par moscou
un dossier brûlant qui n'a pas manqué de
faire réagir emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état français a dit je cite vouloir
bannir un nouvel ordre de sécurité en
europe avec l'otan face à la russie
déclaration devant le parlement de
strasbourg où le chef de l'état est venu
présenter les grands lignes de la
gouvernance française de lieu un grand
oral qui ai pris des allures de meeting
électoral plusieurs députés français
comme yannick jadot ou jardins de
bardella sont venus l'interpeller
donnant lieu parfois de véritables
joutes verbales on en fera l'analyse
et au sommaire à 21h la propagation du
variant omicron dans le monde est de
nouveau record de contamination en
france mais pour autant les restrictions
sanitaires sont elles toujours aussi
nécessaire un nouveau conseil de défense
doit avoir lieu demain alors que de
nombreux français espère un allègement
des mesures à l'instar de l'angleterre
c'est le cas des patrons de discothèques
dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous irons à la rencontre de
l'un d'entre eux qui se sont impuissants
et ne croient plus en tout ces
protocoles alors les français sont-ils
résignait on attend vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme verte et france
le secrétaire d'état américain a montré
aujourd'hui son soutien à l'ukraine en
visite à kiev anthony blinken a annoncé
une aide supplémentaire de 200 millions
de dollars pour la sécurité du pays pour
la russie cette annonce constitue une
menace imminente on en parle tout de
suite avec à notre correspondant à
moscou vera goffman bonsoir verra alors
ce soir il y a encore bon nombre de
spéculations autour de dole offensive
imminente russe en ukraine comment
moscou répond à ces accusations
bonsoir stéphanie et la russie se dit
une nouvelle fois contrainte de démentir
des accusations lui prêtant l'intention
d'envahir l'ukraine après l'ambassadeur
russe aux états unis qui a appelé à
mettre fin à l'hystérie et à ne pas
aggraver les tensions à propos du
donbass lui vice ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï riabkov
s'est exprimé sur le dossier ukrainien a
répété que moscou n'a pas l'intention de
s'en prendre à son voisin ukrainien je
vous propose d'écouter
je crois vraiment qu'il n'existe aucun
risque d'une guerre de grande ampleur
éclate en europe ou ailleurs
oui
c'est une voulons et nous
n'entreprendrons aucune action ayant un
caractère agressif nous n'attaquerons
pas l'ukraine nous ne lancerons pas de
frappe nous n'enverrons pas l'ukraine et
cela a été dit des dizaines de fois ces
dernières semaines et je le confirme une
nouvelle fois
ukraine pour nous l'intégration
progressive de l'ukraine à l'otan sans
même avoir obtenu le statut officiel de
pays membres de l'otan constitue une
menace
il s'agit de nos intérêts fondamentaux
de sécurité des centaines de gosses
right to the center of
most rev
si tu échoues nous ferons tout notre
possible pour inverser la situation pour
la rééquilibrer par le biais de la
diplomatie à notre avis les projets
remis aux états unis représentent une
bonne voie vers une solution
diplomatique
exact
des proches
pour dmitri peskov porte-parole du
président russe la situation en ukraine
est extrêmement tendue dit constater que
des armes ils sont livrés et que
diverses manoeuvres de l'otan et de pays
d'europe occidentale
ils sont effectués pour le kremlin tout
cela engendre des tensions à propos de
l'ukraine le tout alors que moscou
martèle qu'il n'ya pas pour objectif de
s'y attaquer et verra le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken donc en
visite à kiev a rencontré le président
ukrainien il a promis une aide
supplémentaire dans le domaine de la
défense
il s'agit effectivement d'un montant de
200 millions de dollars lequel s'ajoute
aux 450 millions de dollars d'aidé
militaire déjà octroyé à la fin de
l'année dernière mais selon anthony
blinken les états unis priviligient
prône la suture la solution diplomatique
et nous nous sommes engagés au cours des
deux derniers mois dans une
concentration intense sur l'ukraine en
raison du renforcement significatif que
nous avons vu des forces russes près de
la frontière ukrainienne
n'a aucune provocation aucune raison
si ce n'est que nous avons une force
très importante nous savons qu'il existe
des plans pour augmenter encore plus
cette force dans un délai très court ils
m'ont et cela donne au président poutine
la capacité également dans un délai très
court de prendre de nouvelles mesures
agressives contre l'ukraine
nous avons essayé de faire comprendre
qu'il y à deux voies pour la russie il y
à la voie de la diplomatie et du
dialogue pour essayer de résoudre
pacifiquement les différends qui lie à
part la diplomatie c'est clairement la
voie préférable c'est clairement la voie
la plus responsable et celle que notre
préférence mais il ya aussi la voie de
la confrontation et de ses conséquences
si la russie choisi de renouveler son
agression
ces déclarations interviennent l'avait
de la rencontre entre anthony blinken et
ses homologues français allemands et
britanniques à berlin ensuite il est
prévu que le secrétaire d'état
américains se rendent pour un entretien
avec sergey lavrov à genève où les chefs
de la diplomatie doivent discuter des
propositions russes en matière de
sécurité européenne alors verra la
russie elle accuse l'ukraine de préparer
des provocations militaires dans l'est
du pays dans la région du dombass
l'ambassadeur russe aux états unis a
notamment mis en garde washington à ne
pas encourager je cite et tête brûlée à
kiev à recourir à de nouvelles
provocations
la situation sur place de ce point de
vue là on verra
selon le chef de la diplomatie ukrainien
métrique ou les bas le cren ne prépare
pas d'opération offensive selon lui les
autorités travaillent uniquement au
renforcement de leurs capacités
défensives et le congrès américain il
serait le partenaire numéro 1 de kiev
quant au chef de la république populaire
autoproclamé de donetsk dinis push et
l'ineris team que la situation dans
l'est de l'ukraine est plus que tendue
et là il évoque l'arrivée de militaires
et d'armes en provenance des états unis
et du canada dans la région écoutez
l'otan s'approchent des frontières de la
russie de plus en plus d'armes sont
apportées sur le territoire ukrainien
des instructeurs arrive des états unis
du canada
l'ukraine déplace une énorme quantité
d'équipement militaire et de personnel
vers la ligne de contact la mobilisation
de bataillons de volontaires et a été
annoncé
l'ukraine utilise des drones de combat y
compris des drones assez dangereux je
parle de bayraktar tv2 mais néanmoins on
dit que c'est le dombass ou la russie
qui prépare une nouvelle fois quelque
chose nous y sommes habitués mais
actuellement les combats ont déjà lieu
au niveau géopolitique
parfois cela devrait se terminer on ne
le sait pas non plus tout le monde se
trouve sous une pression assez sérieuse
enfin le ministère ukrainien de la
défense a affirmé le mardi 18 janvier
que ce un cargo britannique avait fourni
des systèmes de missile nlo l'équivalent
déjà velin américain destiné à détruire
des chars et d'autres véhicules
militaires terrestres merci verhaeghe
hoffman en direct de moscou alors qu'est
l'enjeu est derrière cette tournée
consacrée à la crise ukrainienne
pourquoi le chef de la diplomatie
américaine appelle moscou à choisir la
boîte diplomatique tout en accordant un
soutien financier de son million de
dollars à kiev une communication calculé
deux jours d'un face-à-face russo
américain c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
évêque nous ce soir pour en parler sur
ce plateau régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous en direct également
pour nous accompagner au jeune berg
ancien diplomate français spécialiste de
la russie ainsi que karine bêcher vous
l'ofco professeur invité à l'université
d'état de moscou bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être avec nous on l'a entendu
avec vera goffman antonymes dickens qui
appelle les numéros poutine à choisir la
voie pacifique dans le même temps les
états unis qui a engagé des moyens
supplémentaires envers l'ukraine tout en
n'ayant peut-être aussi certaines
manoeuvres à la frontière ukrainienne on
a du mal à comprendre ce qu'on est au
bord d'une gré d'une guerre concrètement
en ukraine régie son moi je ne le crois
pas je pense que en revanche ce qui est
en train de se passer en ce moment et ce
qui se passe plus globalement depuis
deux mois
provoque une virée une une comment dire
un renforcement d'une sorte de
bilatéralisme dans le monde avec ce
retour de la russie qui a quand même il
faut le reconnaître bien réussi son coup
dans le sens est là elle dialogue à
nouveau directement avec les américains
on sent que les européens sont écartés
ce dialogue d'ailleurs on l'a vu un les
pourparlers qui ont eu lieu pendant ces
dernières semaines ont eu lieu donc
entre chairman ryabkov ça nous a rappelé
un petit peu les époques l'époque de la
guerre de syrie notamment de la bataille
d'alep où on voyait à l'époque c'était
kerry lavrov qu'on voyait en permanence
qui s'étaient substitués d'ailleurs
rendre presque à leur chef d'état obama
et poutine à l'époque et il y avait pour
la question du règlement de la question
syrienne un face à face américains et
russes là on est dans la même dans une
configuration où justement cette
rencontre entre un sergueï lavrov et
anthony blinken a geneve peu pour moi
considère être considérée comme un point
positif pour la russie puisque la russie
a réussi à être entendus et ella ella
imposé il faut le reconnaître un agenda
à c'est comment assez osée sur l'ukraine
demandant et exigent de la part de
l'otan du désengagement sur le fait que
l'ukraine et la géorgie
n'adhéreront jamais à l'otan le reste
tout autour c'est chacun montre ses
muscles chacun
montre à l'autre qu'il est capable
d'influencer qu'il est capable qu'il a
des alliés pour l'otan on le voit c'est
ses propos sur ces informations sur la
présence de nouveaux commande de deux
nouveaux comment de nouvelles livraisons
d'armes notamment de la part des
britanniques et autres on sait que voilà
de part et d'autre il ya 7 7 une manière
de se jauger mutuellement mais c'est
surtout sur le front diplomatique que
russie amérique ont repris une certaine
façon chacun son intérêt je termine là
dessus les haies des états unis ont tout
intérêt de à reprendre mondialement une
sorte de leadership et a montré qu'elle
le sentiment d'affaiblissement qu'on
avait vu notamment à travers la crise
afghane et le retrait désastreux
d'afghanistan et puis la russie à moi
intérêt à montrer que aujourd'hui elle
est un partenaire incontournable qu'elle
a grandi sur la scène internationale et
qu'aujourd'hui il faut compter avec elle
eugène bergues vous avez le même type
d'analysé on est finalement dans les
postures on n'oublie pas joe biden à des
élections de mi-mandat qui approche à
grands pas au final la russie a réussi
une forme de rapports de force en
s'imposant comme une forme de deux
partenaires égal aux etats unis c'est
votre lecture également oui c'est ma
lecture tout à fait mais j'aimerais
quand même la nuance et au plus tôt a
ajouté
al adely ce qui est tout à fait
pertinent de monsieur le sommier bon
vous l'avez dit vous-même il ya un côté
politique interne il ya quand même deux
millions d'ukrainiens aux proches de
l'ukraine qui sont des citoyens
américains ou qui sont des électeurs et
un bio et mai au canada
effectivement devant le mythe hermes
dont on va pas parler des états unis
mais ça rentre en compte puisqu'il y
aura des mythes terne jo byden est très
affaibli critiquer pays dont qui pêche
vois ça c'est la première raison la
seconde c'est vrai que les états unis
resserrent les rangs ils ont besoin de
resserrer les rangs en europe de montrer
qu'ils sont indispensables que sans eux
ya pas de scruter européenne et par
ricochet ils vont créer des obligés en
disant écoutez on vous a aidé vis-à-vis
de soi disant l'ours russe qui vous
menace nous sommes pour protéger et en
échangeant vaut demander eh bien on va
vous demander d'adopter notre position
du réserves de la chine là pas question
de vous défilez ça vous verrez écouter
dans quelques mois ça va paraître
effectifs alors la troisième
effectivement j'ai observé sap rascalou
jour par jour je trouve que les
américains et les anglo saxons je parle
pas de la france et d'allemagne en font
trop et c'est là que ont déséquilibré
autant les russes soit disant été
menaçants par la presse occidentale qui
n'était pas du tout orienté pro moscou
au contraire et là qu'est ce qu'on a
avant de négocier qu'est ce qu'ils font
bon il ya toutes ses livraisons
d'armements sans entrer dans le détail
chiffré les états unis ont livré 3
milliards de dollars d'armements c'est
la moitié du budget craignant il n'y a
pas beaucoup de pays où la moitié du
budget ben israel ne reçoit que le car
l'ukraine bon évidemment si étalé sur
plusieurs années il ya également un
projet de base à berriane c'que vous
regarderez près de la mer d'azov où les
anglais veulent créer une base militaire
tout près du détroit car je vois bien
les choses comme ça c'est pas lui c'est
pas le meilleur moment de négocier dans
le calme dans la concentration
là vraiment oui il ya on en fait trop
d'un côté qui est vraiment qui est
excessif par rapport à l'or alors on
verra si tout ça va se dégonfler dans
les jours à venir il faut le souhaiter
mais c'est comme préoccupant parce que
les accusations monte et il ya un espèce
de rideau de fumée autour de ces
négociations et ça ça crée un sentiment
d'instabilité de peur et donc c'est pas
très favorable à des négociations car
calme où on doit discuter calmement
comme ça a été le cas dans le passé donc
c'est quand même un petit peu
préoccupants il faut souhaiter eu ce jeu
ne va pas trop continuer car on voit
quand même que la russie peine à
convaincre un de ses bonnes intentions
en tout cas de ne pas avoir de mauvaises
intentions avant de vous donner la
parole je voudrais vous faire écouter
peut-être une voix un petit peu
dissonante en france bruno drye maître
de conférences à l'inalco sur justement
l'intérêt qu'aurait la russie a entre
guillemets envahir le cred et je ne
pense pas que la russie est en ce moment
vraiment intérêt à prendre le contrôle
de l'ukraine vu la situation économique
de l'ukraine je pense en revanche que la
russie fait pression pour avoir des
négociations globales l'ukraine étant
qu'un élément dans le jeu international
pour les russes il s'agit de rétablir un
équilibre entre la russie les états unis
et l'otan l'ukraine n'est qu'un terrain
d'exercice parmi d'autres un des
premiers terrain d'exercice entre les
deux superpuissances
c'est vrai que car ils n'avaient chez
google go quand on entend c'est vrai les
médias en france j'entendais encore
revoilà nos confrères de france info
hier soir s'exprimer sur ce même dossier
on n'a pas cette voie là on est persuadé
des mauvaises intentions russes en la
matière pour quelles raisons selon vous
est-ce aussi compliqué pour moscou de
convaincre
c'est difficile pour moscou de
convaincre parce que la pénétration du
discours ou plus dans le discours
médiatique globale est beaucoup plus
faible que la pénétration du discours
global dans le discours us donc à partir
de l'oeil un certain déséquilibre
surtout qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas
oublier quand même que le combat qui se
mène semaine sur deux plans sur plan de
la communication d'une part mais
également sur plan du réel sur plan de
la communication l'on voit effectivement
comme nous intervenons l'ont déjà
souligné une oeuvre montée en puissance
de la rhétorique
mais qui cache aussi assez mal en fait
une absence de volonté de mener une
guerre réelle ce qui finalement n'est
peut être pas mal quand même on voit
effectivement des livraisons d'armes à
l'envoi effectivement à une
puce et agressive mais je suis assez
d'accord avec mr yaakov il y a quand
même très très peu de chances pour que
cela débouche sur un véritable conflit
armé globale comme nous en avons déjà
connu par le passé en revanche ans il y
existe déjà actuellement un véritable
conflit y est en ce sens
il est vrai que le conflit ukrainiens et
ce que l'on appelle un conflit
secondaire le conflit primaires c'est ce
conflit entre d'une part cette vision
globaliste qui impose un seul centre de
pouvoir un seul centre 10 de décision
les états unis et le retour de bayda
nains et des démocrates à la présidence
l'a affirmé dès le départ ce sont les
états unis qui reprennent ce rôle de
leader contre la vision de la russie qui
est une vision multipolaire s'il ne veut
pas dire le retour aux états-nations
puisqu'il s'agit de paul mais qui
suppose en tout cas l'existence de
plusieurs centres décision politique et
c'est ce combat primaire qui est
fondamental aujourd'hui dans les
relations russo américaines qui explique
les différents terrains sur lesquels se
réalise ensuite de façon régional les on
va dire les rapports de force qu'on peut
créer militaire il n'y a pas que
d'ukraine il a eu aussi la syrie et ne
faut pas l'oublier parce que en syrie
aussi le retour de la russie a été
fondamental et ça a été la première très
grosse défaite du plan atlantiste
puisqu'à partir du moment où sur demande
des autorités syriennes la russie est
intervenue dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
l'on a vu se renverser le rapport de
force entre les groupes terroristes et
les forces syriennes régulière donc il a
effectivement c'est ce décalage entre
d'une part un discours qui est qui monte
en puissance
mais à côté de ça on ne sent pas quand
même une réalité de volonté dit d'une
part ni de l'autre d'entrer dans un
conflit militaire massif un traditionnel
quant à la question de la volonté d'
invasion de de l'ukraine par la russie
c'est assez amusant quand même et
sincèrement franchement grotesque
surtout de le voir répéter comme ça
presque comme un mantra presque tous les
jours par les différends à
l'autorité politique occidentale qui
d'une certaine manière cherche à
formater un discours qui va essayer de
recréer de légitimer leur plan d'action
qui est ce qu ont prouvé mais c'est vrai
quand vous êtes trois intervenants je
voudrais c'est de distribuer la parole
équitablement sur ce plateau en tout cas
anthony blinken poursuit lui sa sa
tournée direction l'allemagne demain
avant genève alors pas en france on
n'aura pas la chance de voir le
secrétaire d'état américain en france
pourtant emmanuel macron a tenu à
s'exprimer sur le sujet aujourd'hui lors
de son premier discours devant le
parlement européen première orale dans
la peau du président du conseil de
l'union européenne je vous propose
justement de l'écouter sur ce dossier
ces prochaines semaines doivent nous
conduire à faire aboutir une proposition
européenne
bâtissant un nouvel ordre de sécurité et
de stabilité
nous devons le construire entre
européens puis le partager avec nos
alliés dans le cadre de l'otan et
ensuite le proposer à la négociation à
la russie alors c'est vrai régis le
sommier cette crise ukrainienne à
l'arrêt vd cette faiblesse d'une défense
européenne ya urgence sur ce sujet elle
a révélé une faiblesse c'est surtout une
absence des européens on a bien compris
que quand les premiers pourparlers ont
eu lieu entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine immédiatement bon job hayden c1
dépêcher d'en parler avant et après
d'informer ses alliés mais parce qu'il y
avait manière de justement de re2 de
l'essec joe biden avait été donc
critiqué sur l'afghanistan et sur la
question du contrat des sous marins
australiens donna d'avoir complètement
piétiner ses alliés ce qui a été la
réalité est là on a remarqué que les
américains voulaient embarquer les
européens simplement les russes nous ne
sont pas d'accord et comment vladimir
poutine l'a dit il a dit que les
européens n'étaient pas assez
indépendant alors peut-être qu'il ya y
at-il dans le deed le message des
manuels macron qui est très important
parce que c'est la première fois qu'un
pays de l'otan à une position prom
promeut comment king qui ne promeut qui
ne met pas l'otan en avant directement
mais l'union européenne l'union
européenne dont on a parlé de ses biens
cela s'entend mais il a eu du mal à
réaliser mais en face on la défense
européenne elle est toujours au point
mort même si elle donne lieu à des
débats régulièrement mon service a
ressuscité ont dit oui tiens il faudrait
peut-être qu'on pense et immédiatement
d'ailleurs vous avez comment comme le
secrétaire de l'otan qui dit non non il
ya déjà l'otan n'y a pas besoin de
découpe défense européenne en gros c'est
ce qu'on entend à chaque fois là
emmanuel macron à une musique un petit
peu différente de celle d' anthony
blinken et des américains il ya le fait
il a pris acte que les américains et les
russes dialogue face à face sans les
européens et lui veut proposer autre
chose peut-être parce que la france
justement est à la tête de l'union
européenne etc pour marquer aussi une
différence mais c'est peut-être aussi
pour marquer une peut-être un
réajustement dans les rapports entre
l'union européenne et la russie jane
bang comment vous l'avez perçu ce
discours d' emmanuel macron concernant
les crises ukrainienne est justement le
rapport face à la russie alors je
l'examiner attentivement parce que je
vais donner un cours de ma là dessus
alors bon il n'y a pas de défense
européenne s'est entendue on va pas
faire un cours théorique là-dessus il
n'y a pas d'art il n'ya pas d'armée
européenne n'y a pas d'état major au
caire il ya pas de force d'intervention
sauf pour les petites choses qu'on a au
sahel ça si tu n'es une histoire qui
dure depuis disons 60 ans alors par
contre avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour
résident
donc je trouve que discours est très
général par les deux ordres on va tout
le monde parle de l'ordre et j'ai
examiné il dit absolument rien de
nouveau il parle là aussi il dit qu'il
faut pas menacée l'intérêt de
l'intérieur c'est l'article 2 alinéa 4
de l'onu il dit qu'on a le droit de
rentrer dans les alliances et l'article
52 de la chasse quand il dit que c'est
des principes c'est les vieux principe
le seul problème d'achoppement c'est
effectivement est-ce que l'ukraine a le
droit ou non d'adhérer à l'otan ça c'est
le point de friction il faudra bien que
les diplomates des deux côtés trouvent
un compromis pour l'instant c'est
beaucoup plus théorique parce que
personne de sérieux ne veut que
l'ukraine rentrer dans le temps et
pareil la géorgie c'est un et je crois
qu'il faudrait écarter ce prime de
négociation et examiner tous les autres
problèmes c'est à dire la réduction des
tensions le fait qu'on armes pas qu'on
ne menace pas l'autre pays par rapport à
territoire et ainsi de suite donc
s'entendre sur les manoeuvres c'est ce
que ces deux systèmes de mesures de
confiance qui ont été faites pendant la
guerre froide qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre et assez vite et je répète sans
élever la voix et il faut espérer que
sergueï lavrov et anthony blind elle
quand ses vents à genève entamant ces
discussions on a eu des préliminaires au
niveau des hauts fonctionnaires
on aura maintenant les ministres et le
veut c'est que on arrive à négocier et
qu'on arrive à des résultats
substantiels avant le mois de juin avant
le sommet de l'otan où le cren pour être
invité c'est là la priorité du jour il
faut vraiment aller vite et sortir ce
langage un petit peu martial et négocier
avec vraiment avec compétence avec
sérieux et avec vraiment volonté
d'aboutir si effectivement on n'a pas
cette volonté d'aboutir on aura on
n'aura pas des affrontements guerrier
mais on aura une absence d' échanges
économiques on aura des restrictions aux
échanges humains et on aura un problème
de régression dans le domaine de la
stabilité de l'ordre dans les rangs au
sens le plus large oui on sent
effectivement pour la russie c'est une
ligne rouge en ont le c7 cette adhésion
à l'otan qui a aidé mais chez google go
vous pensez que les russes vont avoir
gain de cause il demande cet engagement
ça tarde à venir vous y croyez vous à
cet engagement de la part des
occidentaux et des américains notamment
il semblerait que bien contraire macron
et était justement très très clair sur
la question et qu'il a entièrement
repris la position américaine donc là
dessus ça règle la question de
l'autonomie une politique étrangère de
lignes européennes et d'une question de
défense indépendant de l'otan puisque
finalement très clairement il est
expliqué que non que si l'otan décident
d'intégrer d'ukraine elle le pourra
c'est exactement ce qu'il a dit
lorsqu'il a soulevé la question de la
possibilité d'intégrer de nouveaux états
de la même manière il a attaqué tweets
directement la position russe quand il a
parlé de la question la défense de
l'intégrité territoriale puisque du
point de vue atlantiste le fait que la
crimée après un référendum et après la
chute des tati site et en ukraine suite
au coup d'état du maiden et été
rattachée à l'ukraine est considéré
comme une atteinte à l'intégrité
territoriale du craignait donc en fait à
trouvons a été extrêmement clairs merci
oui à tous les trois régions sous le
sommier cas d'échec au logo et j'aime
bien merci d'avoir été avec nous
savoir apporter votre analyse et on le
disait donc à emmanuel macron qui a donc
pris la parole devant le parlement
européen en cours d'un discours qui a
marqué les débuts de la présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne un discours sur fond
également de campagne présidentielle en
france 1 pour en parler on retrouve tout
de suite notre reporter david kelly
fabre ou soir david vous êtes donc
devant l'opéra garnier qui était
jusque-là intenté aux couleurs de
l'europe bon nombre de monuments
parisiens d'ailleurs comme l'assemblée
nationale le son il ya d'ailleurs des
herbes de palais bourbon au parlement
européen aujourd'hui
effectivement à stéphanie ils étaient
teintées de bleu l'opéra garnier mais ce
soir il ya seulement le drapeau européen
qui a flotté dans l'air on pouvait
s'attendre à un règlement de compte et
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé à
strasbourg aujourd'hui dès l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron le climat était très
tendue froidement accueillie dans les
bâtiments du parlement européen des
huées se sont fait entendre macron
coupables ont scandé à certaines
personnes le ton est donné le chef de
l'état ne s'est pas laissé déstabiliser
pour autant et à faire un discours d'une
vingtaine de minutes pour présenter le
programme de la présidence française de
l'union européenne jusqu'en juin et
juste derrière yannick jadot le candidat
europe ecologie les verts s'est livré à
un véritable réquisitoire à l'encontre
du chef de l'état seul candidat à
l'elysée élu à strasbourg il avait
pourtant assuré qu'il ne transformerait
pas cette tribune d'un jour en meeting
mais dès le début de son intervention à
yannick jadot attaques le président de
la république écoutez
vous resterez dans l'histoire monsieur
le président de la république le
président de l'inaction climatique
parce qu'au fond vous êtes un climato
arrangeant vous préféré signer d
armistice avec les lobbys plutôt que de
mener la guerre contre le dérèglement
climatique
vous préférez
procrastiner tel mery streep dans le
film don't look up
reporter renoncer
fantasmer sur des solutions dans dix
quinze ou vingt ans
plutôt que de décréter comme nous
voulons faire la mobilisation générale
alors pour la petite anecdote ans dans
le film évoqué par yannick jadot donc le
cup la dirigeante américaine au pouvoir
incarné par meryl streep ne cesse de
sous-estimer la menace d'une astéroïde
en dépit des alertes scientifiques ce
qui conduit au désastre parenthèse
refermée les autres eurodéputés français
en ont profité pour régler leur compte
également l'accusant emmanuel macron de
se servir de cette présidence de l'union
européenne comme marchepied électorale
pour reprendre les mots de mano aubry
élue de la france insoumise même son
cloche pour jordan bardella du
rassemblement national je cite l
élection présidentielle d 10 et 24 avril
prochain ne décidera pas seulement du
sort de la france mais celui de l'europe
tout entière et davide mais l'électron
quelque peu chahuté 1 donc on peut le
dire mais avant tout de même il a
présenté ses priorités les priorités de
la présidence française pour l'europe
tellement chahuté stéphanie qu'il a
refusé de répondre à la presse après son
intervention plusieurs médias n'ont pas
pu interroger le président alors qu'un
point presse était prévue sa
justification est temps qu'il avait déjà
tout dit en décembre dernier les
journalistes sur place ont donc attendu
cinq heures sur place pour rien alors
que retenir malgré tout de ce premier
discours devant les eurodéputés et bien
qu emmanuel macron souhaite répondre aux
défis climatiques et du numérique
assurer l'indépendance de l'europe ou
encore renforcer la reconnaissance du
droit à l'avortement écouter
vingt ans après la proclamation de notre
charte des droits fondamentaux qui a
consacré notamment l'abolition de la
peine de mort partout dans l'union je
souhaite que nous puissions actualiser
cette charte notamment pour être plus
explicite sur la protection de
l'environnement ou la reconnaissance du
droit à l'avortement
autre point important à le président
français plaident pour faire de l'union
européenne une puissance d'avenir mais
un sac à pâtisser sa capacité d'action
est mise en doute un par le télescopage
avec la campagne pour l'élection
présidentielle d'avril en france un
scepticisme ressentie par l'eurodéputé
allemand m en frais d'un waeber nous
n'avons pas besoin de mots et d'action
selon à ces mots ou encore par la
présidence du groupe socialiste
l'espagnol iratxe garcía pérez est cette
présidence ne fera pas dans l'histoire
grâce à vos talents d'orateur mais grâce
à ce que tous ensemble nous serons
capables de réaliser un avertissement
sans frais pour emmanuel macron merci
david kelly faé pour en parler nous
sommes sur ce plateau avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude merci
d'être avec nous
david kelly fait nous a parlé un de ce
chat u17 ce parlement européen aux
allures voilà d'assemblée nationale le
mercredi après midi les députés nos
voisins d'ailleurs européens ont été
nombreux à pas voir vraiment goûté ce
moment et ce mélange des genres alors
comme le dit jean luc mélenchon est ce
que le président français n'aurait pas
eu intérêts à décaler cette présidence
comme l'a fait d'ailleurs l'ont fait en
leur temps les allemands il ya deux
aspects dans cette question l'aspect
technique c'est que on ne peut pas baser
son tour on a signé un traité il ya un
ordre de passage à la présidence on doit
le respecter sauf seule exception si on
peut s'arranger avec le précédent est le
suivant dans le suivant c'est le
portugal portugal est pas envie
d'avancer de six mois parce qu'ils
élèvent élections donc le même problème
et le le précédent c'était la slovénie
n'a pas ou n'avaient pas très envie non
plus d'échanger sa présidence avec
l'anneau l'aspect politique c'est le
fond du sujet c'est que je pour moi ce
que emmanuel macron est absolument ravi
que les deux choses comme incident
puisque en 2017 il était le premier
candidat à la présidence de la
république a axé sa campagne sur je suis
européen et je veux davantage d'europe
et il est parti pour faire la même chose
cette fois ci lorsqu'il déclara vraiment
candidat pour l'élection de cette année
est en effet en constatant que les
sondages disent qu environ 55 % des
français sont plutôt favorables à
l'europe qui ne veulent pas en sortir
qui veut pas sortir de l'euro d'ailleurs
on voit bien à ce sujet que les
candidats à l'extrême droite et à
l'extrême gauche ont changé d'attitude
puis la campagne précédente celle de
2017 plus aucun d'entre eux ne proposent
sortir de l'union européenne ni même de
l'euro ils proposent d'amender mélenchon
lui propose de désobéir c'est à dire que
quand on n'est pas d'accord avec une
décision décision prise avec l'accord de
l'état mans puisque beaucoup de
décisions se prennent à l'unanimité ou
au conseil européen eh bien on ne
l'appliquent pas alors ça aussi le
mérite pour pour mâcon 2 marc et les
divisions qui existent au sein des
républicains il ya encore des
eurosceptiques et au sein du parti
socialiste
d'autres partis de gauche il ya aussi
des eurosceptiques et je pense que c'est
en effet une stratégie qu'il a
délibérément choisi car vous venez de
nous expliquer effectivement l'intérêt
qu'il avait a occupé entre guillemets
c'est ces deux postes bien qu'il y en
est une qui ne soit pas encore vraiment
officiel il faut aussi souligner c'est
une tribune médiatique de choix pour
emmanuel macron moi j'étais frappé quand
même les chaînes info tout l'après-midi
y ait eu des heures et des heures des
manuels macron en discours répondant aux
questions un temps de parole qui n'est
pas comptée par le csa ont pour le
moment non puisque institutionnellement
l'effet llp qui représente le pays qui
assume la présidence pendant ces six
mois où pendant moins si par hasard il
est paré lui donc je crois que la france
étant considéré comme un pays fondateur
de la construction européenne elle a son
rôle à jouer et en effet si vous
interrogiez maquereau ou ses
collaborateurs il vous répondrait
probablement qu'on parle assez peu
d'europe en temps normal puisque c'est
un sujet qui est considéré comme
ennuyeux comme fastidieux et comme
repoussant les auditeurs par conséquent
et vous dirais que c'est une
compensation un renvoi qu'il ya aussi de
la politique européenne qui rejoint ce
moment là la politique française puisque
parmi les annonces fortes sa volonté de
réformer schengen et retrouver la
maîtrise de ses frontières là aussi
comme des airs de campagne une petite
musique qu'on entend beaucoup sur cette
campagne présidentielle française alors
je crois que la nature les faits tous
les candidats veulent une réforme une
réforme importante et veulent que
l'union européenne recouvre la maîtrise
de ses frontières alors il ya
effectivement le président l'a mentionné
frontex dont les moyens ont été
renforcés mais doivent être encore plus
renforcée c'est une sorte de deux corps
de gardes frontières européens mais il
ya aussi le traité de schengen qui doit
être totalement revue avec notamment le
fait que ce soit le pays de premier
arrivé des migrants qui est la charge
d'instruire et éventuellement de
renvoyer dans leur pays d'origine les
les migrants en question qui n'est pas
bien évidemment puisque c'est faire
supporter un poids excessif à l'italie à
l'espagne à la grèce et tout ceci doit
être revue et en effet et il est tout à
fait nécessaire que l'union européenne
retrouve la maîtrise de ses frontières
et de ses flux dans ça suppose un
partage des responsabilités entre états
membres qui n'est pas facile et qui ne
sera pas facile à établir alors vous
restez avec nous si vous le voulez bien
que le blanchet saison puisqu'on va
aborder un autre point d'actualité
internationale dans l'oeil du cyclone un
boris johnson annonce aujourd'hui la
levée de l'essentiel des mesures
sanitaires en angleterre une décision
qui intervient donc en plein partie
gates le scandale qui a révélé les
soirées arrosées du premier ministre
pendant les confinements l'opposition et
aussi les députés de son propre camp
demande sa démission martial peuvion
après avoir examiné attentivement les
données le cabinet a conclu qu'une fois
la réglementation caduc le gouvernement
ne rendra plus obligatoire le port de
masques faciaux où que ce soit
port du masque obligatoire
télétravail recommandé et pas sanitaires
voici quelques-unes des mesures qui
disparaîtront dès la semaine prochaine
en angleterre comme l'a annoncé ce
mercredi boris johnson mais en plein
scandale du parti gate qui a révélé que
l'homme politique de 57 ans avait
participé à plusieurs soirées arrosées
en plein confinement la levée de telles
mesures s'apparentent à une stratégie
visant à redorer l'image d'un premier
ministre en mauvaise posture alors qu'il
vit sa pire crise depuis son accession
au pouvoir en 2019 le locataire de
downing street voit sa popularité
s'effriter un peu plus chaque jour
si le principal intéressé a multiplié
les excuses à la télévision ces derniers
jours la polémique a donné à
l'opposition le parti travailliste
l'occasion d'enfoncer un peu plus boris
johnson
alors que les personnes invitées à la
fête le vin mais avait des dettes
informé qu'il s'agissait d'un événement
social le premier ministre nous demande
de croire que lui seul avait été informé
qu'il s'agissait d'une réunion de
travail
ils nous demandent aussi d'accepter
qu'en se frayant un chemin parmi les
bouteilles vides et les plateaux de
sandwichs il n'a pas réalisé qu'il
s'agissait d'une fête
le premier ministre se rend-il compte à
quel point cela semble ridicule
plusieurs députés du parti de boris
johnson se sont également réunis ce
mardi pour discuter d'une stratégie
d'éviction du premier ministre
j'attends de mes dirigeants qu'ils
assument la responsabilité des actions
qu'ils entreprennent
hier boris johnson a fait le contraire
de cela je lui rappellerai donc une
citation bien trop familière pour lui de
les oem riches à neville chamberlain
tu es resté assis là trop longtemps pour
tout le bien que tu as fait au nom de
dieu par pour l'évincer de son poste il
faudrait qu au moins 54 députés envoie
un courrier réclamant son départ au
comité des députés conservateurs une
trentaine l'aurait déjà fait selon la
presse anglaise
sept d'entre eux ont reconnu
publiquement avoir accompli cette
démarche dont christian houette ford qui
a annoncé ce mercredi quitté le parti
conservateur pour rejoindre l'opposition
travailliste le député a été
chaleureusement accueilli par kerry
starmer le leader du parti un coup dur
de plus pour boris johnson dont les
jours sont peut-être comptés à la tête
du royaume uni présent vous êtes
toujours avec nous et effectivement les
jours peut-être compter sur un siège
éjectable même en ce sens qu ils se
montrés déterminés à vouloir rester en
poste est ce qu'il va réussir son pari
selon vous c'est pas tout à fait
impossible en effet aujourd'hui
l'annoncé anticipée de mesures qui
prendront caire entreront en vigueur le
27 donc dans huit jours
suppression du port du masque
suppression du pass vaccinale pour
entrer dans les boîtes de nuit ou dans
les endroits ya beaucoup de monde tout
ça va dans le sens de ce que
souhaitaient les députés conservateurs
parce que les députés conservateurs
considèrent qu'il faut respecter la
liberté des individus des citoyens et
qui sont assez grands pour savoir ce
qu'il doit faire suite à ces
responsables un petit peu la philosophie
du parti conservateur britannique donc
là il leur donne un gage est en effet en
tenant ce gage il est possible que il
arrive à estomper un peu l'odeur de
scandale de ce qui s'est passé le 20 mai
2020 et à d'autres occasions alors il a
confié à la numéro deux de
l'administration du premier ministre le
soin d'effectuer une enquête cette
personne qui est assez respectés dans
l'administration britannique va rendre
les conclusions de son enquête d'ici
quelques jours est ce qu elle n'osera
incriminés boris johnson pour sa
participation à la fête du vin mais 2020
c'est possible ça n'est pas sûr elle a
un petit peu l'avenir politique de boris
johnson entre ses mains mais au bout du
compte c'est le leadership du parti
conservateur qui a son avenir entre ses
mains parce que le parti conservateur ne
votera la destitution de boris johnson
que s'il a la certitude d'avoir un
meilleur leader pour gagner les
élections partielles qui vont venir dans
les mois prochains et puis les élections
générales qui viendront en leur temps le
fait que le parti travailliste demande
sa démission c'est normal joue son rôle
mais le parti travailliste n'y peut rien
actuellement le parti conservateur à une
très large majorité aux communes en
dépit du transfuge qui a traversé la
chambre ce matin on le disait il annonce
donc la levée de l'essentiel des
restrictions liées au co vite vous
l'avez dit vous-même ça pourrait
peut-être le sauver n'est ce pas là la
façon la plus éclatante de démontrer que
en fait ces restrictions sanitaires
parfois elles sont politiques tout
simplement bien sûr et encore une fois
là aussi le il ya sans doute un clivage
entre les travaillistes et les
conservateurs sur ce point et là il a
deux manifestement donné des gages aux
caciques de son qui n'aimait pas ces
mesures restrictives de la liberté
individuelle et là on voit bien que
comme vous dites il y à un clivage
politique
est-ce qu'il faut laisser les citoyens
qui sont assez grands pour savoir ce
qu'ils ont à faire ou est-ce qu'il faut
leur imposer des contraintes vaccinale
ou autre mais c'est vrai que lorsqu'il
ya péril en la demeure c'est aussi le
devoir de l'état d'imposer des
contraintes pour sauver la population de
ces périls et ce n'est pas le cas en
tout cas puisqu'elles sont levés merci
toad blanche raison d'avoir été avec
nous et expert en relations
internationales
et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale inquiétudes de reporters
sans frontières en tunisie une alerte
suite à de violentes répressions suivie
par de nombreux journalistes étaient en
marge des célébrations du 11e
anniversaire de la révolution le rapport
souligne la dégradation de la liberté de
la presse dans le pays mais c'est mme
shelly c'est un rapport d'une trentaine
de pages intitulé l'heure de vérité et
publié quelques jours après la violente
répression observée lors des
manifestations du 14 janvier dernier à
tunis à l'occasion du 11e anniversaire
de la révolution rsf pointe du doigt le
danger qui pèse sur les acquis
démocratiques 2011 et les violations de
la liberté de la presse de plus en plus
flagrante ces dernières années notamment
depuis le 25 juillet 2021 date du coup
de force du président kaïs sayed dans
son rapport reporters sans frontières
revient également sur les relations
ambiguës entre les médias à la sphère
politique et le monde des affaires est
réel obstacle à la mise en oeuvre des
réformes nécessaires pour garantir
l'indépendance des journalistes
l'augmentation des exactions commises à
l'encontre de ces derniers elle n'a fait
que confirmer les inquiétudes de la
société civile quant au réel engagement
du président sayed dans ce domaine
écoutez il ya une recrudescence des
attaques et de la et des entraves au
travail journalistique depuis le 25
juillet devant un mutisme total de
carthage et du présent price is right on
a aussi parlé des liens
entre
les médias certains médias en tunisie et
les hommes d'affaires véreux et leur
l'alignement de certains
l'alignement total de certains médias
sur sur des
partis politiques ou des candidats à la
présidentielle en 2019 notamment et
surtout
l'échec de des réformes du secteur
médiatique tunisien qui sans cela et
c'est la responsabilité
bien sûr des partis politiques et des
gouvernements tunisiens qui n'ont pas
agi pour
mettre en oeuvre les garanties que
contient la constitution tunisienne en
matière de liberté de la presse et de
l'information de l'avis de certains
observateurs ces intimidations
découlerait même d'une volonté direct du
palais de carthage qui malgré les
nombreuses réunions entre le ministère
de l'intérieur et le syndicat national
des journalistes tunisiens n'a pris
aucune mesure pour protéger et faciliter
l le travail des journalistes écouter
la situation est très mauvaise en
tunisie en ce qui concerne la liberté de
la presse et la liberté d'expression en
général mais aussi en ce qui concerne la
sécurité physique des journalistes et
leur accès à l'information de nombreux
indices montrent que la liberté de la
presse se détériore aujourd'hui
notamment au vu des récentes attaques
contre des journalistes sur l'avenue
habib bourguiba plus d'une vingtaine de
journalistes hommes et femmes ont été
victimes d'agressions
diverses agressions dont des violences
physiques des arrestations musclées sans
parler de la destruction de leur
matériel de telles attaques de la police
sont devenus répétitives malgré nos
réunions répéter avec le ministère de
l'intérieur tout cela nous laisse à
penser que ces attaques contre les
journalistes sont une politique
systématique
alors qu'elle incarnait le symbole du
progrès en termes de liberté
d'expression dans le monde arabe depuis
le départ de ben ali la tunisie occupe
aujourd'hui la 73e place dans le
classement mondial de la liberté de la
presse au titre de 2021 selon le rapport
de rsf et sur le continent africain
toujours une vingtaine de rebelles et
d'opposants ont été libérés hier au
tchad une amnistie générale votée le
mois dernier objectif instaurer un
climat favorable en vue du dialogue
national prévu fin février avec la
participation de mouvements rebelles le
tchad veut tourner la page de la
transition dix mois après la mort du
président deby françois xavier lambert
à peine libéré cette vingtaine de
détenus tchadien prennent place pour une
cérémonie officielle
devant la prison de claix soupe située à
une vingtaine de kilomètres de djamena
plusieurs officiels leur font face dont
le ministre de la justice ce dernier se
félicite de ce premier pas réalisé dans
le cadre d'une amnistie générale
concernant 296 détenus en prélude au
dialogue national inclusif en
préparation et afin de permettre à tous
les fils et filles du tchad et d'y
participer les plus hautes autorités
elle décidé d'administrer les
compatriotes pour des faits d'atteintes
à l'intégrité de l'état et aux délits
d'opinion
cette mesure d' amnistie générale
concerne d'anciens membres de groupes
armés détenu et jugé pour terrorisme
mais certains des prisonniers libérés
redoute que les autorités bloquent les
autres libérations sommes nombreux matin
personne et les seize personnes sans
abri dans ce sens là dedans et c'était
vraiment une et que notre inquiétude est
est ce que le cnt est libéré dans les
jours qui viennent
cette amnistie générale constitue
également l'une des exigences formulées
par les principaux groupes rebelles pour
venir à la table des négociations avec
le pouvoir en dialogue souhaité par le
nouveau président tchadien et qui doit
conduire à des élections présidentielle
et législatives la réunion est
programmée pour le 15 février prochain
mais plusieurs partis d'opposition met
en doute la sincérité du pouvoir
l'actuel président mahama débit a pris
la tête du conseil militaire de
transition au lendemain de la mort de
son père idriss deby l'ancien président
a été tué en avril dernier dans des
combats alors qu'il s'était rendu sur la
ligne de front aux côtés de ces trous
en chine la détention d'un écrivain
australien d'origine chinoise crispé les
relations entre pékin et canberra de
quoi raviver les tensions entre les deux
pays sur tous les plans et yamina
benguigui da
les tension grimpe entre la chine et
l'australie et pour cause canberra
accusent pékin de détenir arbitrairement
un écrivain australien d'origine
chinoise
il ya un grain john et de ne pas lui
apporter le soutien médical adéquat nous
sommes préoccupés par sa santé et nous
avons toujours été clairs sur le fait
qu'il doit recevoir le traitement
nécessaire pour préserver sa santé
physique et mentale l'homme incarcéré
est un romancier à succès connu pour ses
romans d'espionnage
ironie du sort c'est précisément pour
des accusations d'espionnage qui les
détenus en chine est soumis à un procès
qui a débuté l'année dernière à huis
clos de son côté pékin rejette les
accusations de lost règle nous avons
exposé la position de la chine sur cette
affaire à de multiples occasions je
tiens à souligner à nouveau que la chine
est un pays fondée sur l'état de droit
et que les autorités chinoises chargées
de l'application de la loi traite cette
affaire dans le strict respect de la loi
tous les droits et intérêts légaux de
yang wang chun ont été pleinement
protégés nous opposons fermement aux
perturbations à justifiable de la partie
australienne dans le traitement des
affaires conformément à la loi et à
l'ingérence flagrante dans la
souveraineté judiciaire de la chine
l'écrivain continue de son côté à nier
les accusations
arrêté lors d'un retour en chine depuis
son domicile aux états unis en janvier
2019 il a depuis déclaré à ses partisans
avoir été torturé alors qu'il se
trouvait dans un site de détention à la
veille de son procès ayant craint john
aurait subi plus de 300 interrogatoire
en 26 mois une détention qui cristallise
des tensions diplomatiques entre chine
et australie crispation qui s'est
intensifiée ces dernières années avec la
demande par canberra de l'ouverture
d'une enquête indépendante sur les
origines de la pandémie de coronavirus
nous avons besoin de connaître des
détails que seul un rapport indépendant
peut nous permettre de comprendre sur
l'origine du virus sur la manière d'y
faire face et sur la transparence avec
laquelle les informations ont été
partagés dans le même temps le géant
chinois des télécommunications huawei
avait été exclu des appels d'offres sur
le déploiement du réseau 5g en australie
en représailles pékin avait engagé une
série de mesures contre une dizaine de
produits australiens des actions que
l'envoyé spécial de joe byden au
pacifique associe à une véritable guerre
économique entre les deux pays c'est
peut-être la diplomatie du guerrier loue
une guerre économique vraiment
spectaculaire dirigée contre l'australie
je suis sûr qu'il ya une meilleure façon
de le décrire mais c'est certainement ce
à quoi ça ressemble des actions plus
affirmée dans la mer de chine
méridionale à travers le détroit de
taïwan
la mer orientale des actions brutales le
long de la frontière avec l'inde vous
additionnez tout cela et vous voyez une
chine qui prend plus de risques qui
s'affirme davantage une situation qui
permet aux états unis de placer ses
pions en mer de chine zone stratégique
crucial dans la région indo pacifique
joe biden ayant passé un accord
remarquer avec canberra pour
l'exploitation de sous marins à
propulsion nucléaire qui devrait
permettre à l'australie d'accroître
considérablement ses forces de
dissuasion militaire
pour les directions présent le pérou qui
fait face à une marée noire après
l'éruption d'un volcan îles tonga depuis
quatre jours les autorités locales ont
fermé l'accès aux plages de la région un
pétrolier a été secoué par les fortes
vagues et a déversé sa cargaison en mer
les détails avec nicolas petit
ces images aériennes témoignent des
dégâts sur cette plage le sable et peu à
peu recouvert par une épaisse couche
noire un spectacle de désolation
relevées par les autorités
nous pouvons constater de gros dégâts
sur cette plage nous devrons déterminer
leur ampleur leur gravité et aussi parlé
avec la raffinerie
cette raffinerie dont parle le ministre
de l'environnement péruvien est dans le
collimateur d'après l'agent ce péruvien
and evaluation et d'application des lois
environnementales
elle n'aurait pas adopter de mesures
immédiates afin de prévenir des dommages
cumulatif ou plus grave qui affecte le
sol l'eau la flore la faune et les
ressources hydro biologique et ce
constat est très largement partagé par
les pêcheurs devant le travail de
ramassage effectué par les équipes de
cette raffinerie
d'après ce que nous voyons il n'y prête
pas beaucoup d'attention ils prennent
seulement le sable de surfaces
contaminées que l'on voit sur la plage
mais nous ne les voyons pas enlever le
pétrole brut qui est mélangé à l'eau
on ne voit pas grand chose ici mais dans
les rochers c'est énorme
la marée noire et épaisse trop épaisses
et elles tuent les animaux
cette marée noire signifie la mort de
tout l'hydro biologie la diversité de
tous les bancs de pêche de vente alia à
wangen et affecte toute une génération
des pêcheurs et tout le commerce en
général
repsol a tué la faune marine peut-on
lire sur cette pancarte d'un manifestant
pour dénoncer cette marée noire et ses
conséquences une manifestation a eu lieu
devant la raffinerie détenus par le
groupe pétrolier espagnol
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la crise sanitaire en
france des restrictions sont elles
toujours nécessaire dans notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français nous irons à
la rencontre d'un patron de discothèque
ils ne croient plus en tout ces
protocoles alors les français sont qu il
résigné
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
mais
l'afrique a été la cible de 28 millions
de cyber attaques entre janvier et août
2020 est elle devenue la nouvelle terre
de prédilection des cybercriminels nous
non quand cruellement de compétences
qualifiées en termes de cybersécurité on
estime que 96% des incidences de
cybersécurité ne serez pas elle si elle
est ou resterait non résolus qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire sur l'action des étals
sont à la fois régulateur mais aussi
coupable de la situation les budgets
alloués à la cyber sécurité en afrique
reste très très très insuffisant 15 pays
africains seulement possède une
stratégie nationale de cybersécurité et
ça fait que ça risque réellement de
créer le chaos dont tout le continent
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
le new york times le washington post the
guardian
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
où
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit bout de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france voyez à la rivière lie à tous
mais c'est un peu dégueulasse
l'onic awashish ont
passé une tp il me dit qu'il n'ya même
pas de pain donc là je lui donnais une
compote qui est bien sûr est est ce que
vous avez une idée de qui sont ces gens
qui attaquent un lycée
sapa
en face
[Musique]
mais s'accroche
[Applaudissements]
veut contenir tout le monde sur l'île
évidemment que l'on est assis sur une
poudrière enfin moi je leur jette même
pas la pierre c'est bien m'accueillir
mais je casse les a mollo redonne de
l'espoir puis à la fin on leur dit quoi
non mais t'as pas de papiers mais écoute
accroche toi mais j'ai pas de conneries
pour une fois qu'on a la parole a aussi
dit mais est-ce que ce qu'on leur a
apporté est ce que ce système là ce
qu'il est bon pour moi le gros point
d'interrogation
exception française sentiment d'être
oubliés qui sont ces habitants qui
vivent à 8000 kilomètres de l'hexagone
est content il à nous dire entre
grandeur et misère nous sommes allés à
leur rencontre
[Musique]
tous
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la propagation du variant
omicron dans le monde est de nouveau
record de contamination en france mais
pour autant les restrictions sanitaires
sont elles toujours aussi nécessaire un
nouveau conseil de défense doit avoir
lieu demain alors que de nombreux
français espère un allègement des
mesures à l'instar de l'angleterre
aujourd'hui c'est le cas notamment des
patrons de boîtes de nuit dans notre
rubrique en pensent les français nous
irons à la rencontre de l'un d'entre eux
qui se sentent impuissants et ne croient
plus en tous ces protocoles alors les
français sont pile résignés on attend
nos rêves aux élections sur le conte
télégramme daté france
la circulation sans précédent de mikron
dans notre pays inquiète l'exécutif un
conseil de défense sanitaire réunit
demain à l'elysée doit donner de la
visibilité sur les restrictions pour
l'om est ce bien que moins virulent le
variant restera dangereux ces prochains
mois dans le même temps un autre son de
cloche plus optimiste fait son bonhomme
de chemin pour plusieurs experts le coc
vite s'apprêterait rentrer dans une
phase endémique grégoire douce et
cette pandémie est loin d'être terminée
et avec l'incroyable croissance dod
mikron au niveau mondial de nouveaux
variants sont susceptibles d'apparaître
alors qu'elle secoue la planète depuis
deux ans nous serions encore loin d'en
avoir terminé avec la pandémie mais si
les propos du patron de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé n'incite pas à un
optimisme démesuré un autre son de
cloche prend de l'ampleur ces derniers
temps le virus s'apprêterait à entrer
dans une phase endémique nous ne devons
donc pas oublier que nous sommes
toujours dans une situation de pandémie
est néanmoins avec l'augmentation de
l'immunité dans la population et avec
omicron il y aura beaucoup d'immunité
naturelle en plus de la vaccination nous
dirigerons rapidement vers un scénario
où nous serons plus proches de
l'endémicité
un discours qui trouve un écho chez
certains dirigeants politiques comme en
suisse où le ministre de la santé évoque
un possible début de la fin de la
pandémie ou encore en espagne le
gouvernement sanchez s'apprête à changer
de cap dans sa stratégie sanitaire la
situation n'est pas la même qu'il y a un
an nous connaissons mieux le virus la
science connaît mieux le virus en
attendant de voir ce que disent les
rapports les plus concluants sur le
variant omicron qui est plus contagieux
mais paraître plus léger en ce qui
concerne les symptômes je pense donc que
nous devons aller vers une surveillance
de l'évolution du coc vide comme une
maladie endémique d'une pandémie que
nous avons vécu jusqu'à aujourd'hui
une maladie endémique qu'est ce que cela
signifie vraiment au juste dans ce type
de scénario le virus circule toujours de
façon permanente dans un espace
géographique ou chez une population
donnée peut-être selon des facteurs
saisonniers mais avec un risque plus
limité pour la santé à l'image de la
grippe par exemple cette circulation
permanente du virus fait que notre
immunité est régulièrement stimuler et
se renforcent à chaque rencontre avec le
virus de fait les manifestations
cliniques de la maladie deviennent moins
sévère avec le temps chez des personnes
de mieux en mieux protégées il faudra
certainement un peu plus de temps pour
savoir si cette approche théorique se
mue en vérité elle pourrait alors
bouleverser les stratégies de lutte
contre le coc vite 19 mai cette question
risque de continuer à nourrir de
nombreux débats dans les semaines à
venir
mais on va continuer ce débat pour en
parler nous sommes avec philippe froguel
chercheur généticien bonsoir philippe
froguel merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct je le rappelle à chaque fois
mais enfin vous avez quand même été le
premier je m'en souviens il ya très
longtemps à nous dire que omicron si
omicron ne s'avérait pas dangereux ce
serait peut-être vous l'aviez lié à
l'époque la fin de la pandémie en tout
cas on irait vraiment dans le bon sens
aujourd'hui on le voit il ya les
optimistes y est les plus pessimistes
vous vous vous situez dans quel camp
moi je pense que ça dépend des deux
camps on parle pour l'instant en france
en tout cas on est à cinq cent mille cas
par jour on n'est pas au pic et c'est
pas une surprise parce que on a quinze
jours de retard à paris à peu près trois
semaines un mois dans le reste de la
france et donc le pic
si vous comptez le nombre total de cas
ça sera probablement à la fin du mois
mais ensuite je pense que ça va baisser
baisser rapidement comment en afrique du
sud comme en angleterre et je pense
j'espère que si le variant delta
disparaît comme il en train de faire
doucement mais sûrement eh bien on va
s'en sortir par les hôpitaux ce qui veut
pas dire qu'il n'est pas des gens qui
vont encore mourir mais ça sera pas au
niveau de la santé publique le drame
qu'on a connu ces derniers temps alors
on espère évidemment pour la fin de
cette épidémie pandémie peu importe
comment on l'appelle mais en tout cas
que le virus nous laisse tranquille
n'est ce pas parmi les pessimistes
beaucoup évoquent de nouveaux variants
éventuel également ses 4 milliards
d'êtres humains qui sont toujours non
vaccinés pour vous ces deux éléments
représentent ils un un danger oui c'est
bien entendu un danger de théorique
simplement micro est vraiment très très
très contagieux ça va être difficile
pour un autre variant de faire mieux que
lui mais ce que dit aussi le directeur
de l' oms et que je je pense que c'est
tout à fait vrai c'est que il faut
avancer vers un vaccin de deuxième
génération qui puisse couvrir pas
simplement au micro ou la suite de
micron mais beaucoup plus large et qui
puisse aussi couvrir l'ensemble des
possibles modifications de ces sascoc 2
puisque c'est le nom du du virus et ça
c'est très possible
simplement ce n'est pas sûr que les
vaccins arn soit ce dont on a besoin en
2002 2022 ou 2023 alors il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui s'interrogent notamment
en france envoie que le royaume uni lève
ces restrictions l'espagne dit vouloir
traiter ce virus comme une grippe alors
qu'en france finalement voilà un renfort
ces protocoles avec un pass vaccinale on
connaît le casse-tête dans l'est dans
les écoles quelle position adopter
aujourd'hui parce que beaucoup doutent
d'eux que ces restrictions soient encore
nécessaires
avec cinq cent mille cas répertoriés par
jour c'est à dire probablement à 800
milles 1 million en réalité en fait tout
le monde est touché et on le voit bien
autour de autour de nous
moi je prône les autotests pour au moins
protéger ses proches et puis éviter de
contaminer d'autres personnes
ensuite effectivement une grande partie
de la population française va être
atteinte par au micron qui soient
vaccinées ou non vacciner puisque vaccin
est relativement peu efficace contre les
formes bénignes d'eau micron efficace
contre les formes graves apparemment
mais aujourd'hui il faut attendre que le
pic descendent faire le plus attention
pour soi même et ses proches et je pense
que en février ça ira mieux et langue
pour faire tomber l'angleterre comme en
espagne avoir
considéré qu au niveau sociétal la vie
doit recommencer quand même vous parliez
du vaccin on parle de plus en plus
des médicaments pfizer vient d'en sortir
un est ce que c'est une vraie
alternative aujourd'hui pour vous
difficultés du médicament de pfizer
c'est qui doit être admise très très
très rapidement et pas à l'hôpital
puisque c'est avant que ça se joue et
c'est pas absolument évident aujourd'hui
les médecins généralistes que j'ai
consulté les aides les unions
professionnelles n'ont rien reçu du
gouvernement sur une approche claire à
qui et comment distribuer ce médicament
j'ai bien peur que ce médicament reste
dans les pharmacies ne soient pas
utilisés
merci philippe froguel chercheur
généticien merci nous avoir apporté
votre analyse soirée en tout cas cessé
de mesures de restriction et bien il ya
des professions qui les vivent plus
durement que d'autres et qui les
remettent en cause vu l'évolution de
l'épidémie c'est le cas des patrons de
discothèques qu'en pensent les français
ce soir nous sommes allés à la rencontre
de mathieu lebrun patron d'une boîte de
nuit dans la manche c'était juste avant
les fêtes de fin d'année son
établissement avait pu rouvrir quelques
jours avant de devoir refermer comme
beaucoup de professionnels de son
secteur il ne comprend pas vraiment
l'efficacité de ces mesures reportage et
c'est el farj renault parquet
je suis à saint lô dans la manche je
vais les rencontrer mathieu lebrun c'est
le patron du milton la discothèque qui
se trouve juste derrière moi depuis le
10 décembre elle est fermée comme toutes
les discothèques de france alors comment
lé patron de discothèque ont-ils vécu à
nouveau cette fermeture dans quel état
d'esprit sont ils on va aller lui
demander
bonjour mathieu
merci beaucoup de nous recevoir chez
vous alors vous êtes vous est fermé
depuis le 10 décembre maintenant comment
comment s'est passée cette nouvelle
fermeture écoutez on a ouvert le
mercredi et le jeudi ce qui est on est
encore dans l'autorisation ce qui nous a
permis d'écouler nos stocks vous dire au
revoir nos clients et parce que bon ils
ont beau nous expliquer qu'on va fermer
quatre semaines on est tous à peu près
conscient que ça va durer plus longtemps
que quatre semaines alors je sais bien
que c'est qu'on s'est compliqué pour eux
de gérer cette épidémie mais on a quand
même tous le sentiment que c'est pas une
décision sanitaire de nous fermer c'est
une décision politique qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça et
qu'est ce que cela signifie concrètement
pour vous ce qui nous fait dire ça c'est
que on ouvert depuis le puy 9 juillet
alors au tout début on a parlé de
quelques cents les boîtes de nuit a
priori au retour de ce conseil que nos
syndicats et il ya eu 14 cluster depuis
le 9 juillet dans les boîtes de nuit
alors j'en ai eu un donc c'est à dire
que ma capacité d'accueil à ce moment là
était de 525 personnes huit personnes
contaminées on appelle ça un cluster de
quoi on parle on n'a pas l'impression
d'avoir été plus dangereux qu'une autre
activité oui on a du mal à comprendre et
est ce qu on dit tous tous les patrons
bonne nuit qu'on soit fermé ou ouvert la
fête aura lieu j'imagine que vous avez à
d'autant plus de mal à comprendre cette
fermeture que dans les discothèques le
pass sanitaires et est contrôlé et j'ai
envie de dire sur contrôler parce que
vous demandez aussi les présidences
c'est un peu long je vous propose qu'on
s'assoit
c'est très difficile à comprendre
sachant qu'on avait quand même la plus
haute protection c'est à dire qu'on nous
a expliqué à leur ouverture alors vous
met elle pas sanitaire vous devez et on
a été contrôlé et lourdement contrôlé
pendant tout la berd ouverture dans un
restaurant on arrive on montre un pass
pas de pièces d'identité ça peut être le
passe de n'importe qui et ça rentre dans
les discothèques c'est pas du tout qui
avoue contrôler automatiquement les
identités des gens toute manière moi
pour le milton j'ai eu six contrôles six
fois ils sont venus voir si on a bien
tester les si on a bien fait le test des
spas sanitaire des gens en use refermant
nous aussi un peut-être un aveu de dire
le passage du ter marche pas je pense
que ça fonctionne je pense que c'est
bien mais mais malheureusement ça va
laisser entendre au grand public elle te
rends compte les boîtes de nuit n'avait
plus gros contrôle ils ont fermé et
pourtant vous avez le truc avec ba
sanitaire puisque les identités kekel
quel message on envoie aux gens dans
quel état d'esprit est ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui c'est de la colère c'est
c'est quoi sur la première période sont
les premiers 16 mois on est passé un peu
partout où il y avait beaucoup plus de
colère sur la première période avant
qu'on oro et là il ya de la colère mais
fut
dans l'ensemble je vais moi le premier
je suis plus blasés blasé fatigué
fatigué des décisions qui sont prises
l'édition j'en reviens toujours le bon
sens il y en a plus il a fait aura lieu
il ya des gens qui vont organiser des
soirées des soirées clandestines
et l'état y perdant dans tous les sens
c'est à dire que sanitairement parce
qu'il n'y aura pas de contrôle de passe
à dix terrains du tout et puis
il ya surtout que ces soirées
clandestines sont payantes et l'état on
perde aussi économiques parce que quand
je suis ouvert je paye de la tva de
l'urssaf des charges diverses et variées
que je redistribue à l'état des impôts
bas ça pilotes et en plus ils vont nous
aider financièrement incroyable
mathieu on arrive ici dans le centre
névralgique de la boîte venue du moins
pour vous c'est la caisse ce qui m'amène
à vous demander qu'est-ce que comment ça
va se passer cette fois au niveau des
aides de l'état qu'est ce que l'état
vous a promis alors le chômage partiel
on va voir les coûts fixes c'est à dire
qu'ils prennent toutes les charges la
discothèque et la rémunération du gérant
et on va dire à peu près alléluia parce
que on s'est débrouillé pendant 16 mois
sur la première période où on n'avait
pas de salaire nous les gens mais ce
qu'il faut voir c'est alors ce qui n'est
pas mon cas c'est moi je suis une
discothèque qui fonctionne sur les douze
mois à peu près avec des pics un peu
plus importants que d'autres mais je
pense à mes collègues saisonniers
on va prendre les discothèques qui sont
en stations de montagne qui pendant
cette période c'est le moment où ils
vont gagner leur argent et là on va leur
payer que les coûts fixes comment
vont-ils faire cet été où ils sont
fermés vous aviez imaginé vous retrouver
à nouveau dans cette étude alors on
savait que juillet août septembre
on allait
nous lâcher un peu la grappe évidemment
pensé au moment où le froid allait
revenir et que l'épidémie allait j'avais
toujours ça dans le coin de ma tête et
comme je le dis en plus on sert toujours
un peu de bouc émissaire c'est
psychologiquement dur on parle et adore
de ta je vois ça dure en ce sens je suis
désolé terme ça devient chiant que mais
je pense que c'est un peu le mot que
tous les français doivent pensais pas
que les patrons de boîte de nuit merci
beaucoup merci à vous
avant de passer dans quelques instants
notre débat politique avec nos invités
une petite mise à jour nous accueillons
thierry fontaine qui sait aussi
discothèque président de l'umih dans le
département du rhône bonsoir thierry
fontaine
sujet qu'on vient de voir a été tourné
il ya environ trois semaines le 31
décembre aujourd'hui où en est on à ce
que vous avez été entendus
alors entendu on s'est toujours dernier
moment
sur les aides on avance elles sont
clairement pas suffisante pour pour un
mois de décembre supprimés quand on
supprime le mois qui représente 25% du
chiffre annuel assez difficile juste
payer un coût fixe mais ça évolue en
avançant la discussion avec bercy sur le
sujet donc c'est plutôt
dur ce qui est perdu toute façon est
perdu on récupérera jamais il faut pas
se leurrer nous entreprises elles sont
durement impactée sur les ouvertures on
voit tout ce qui se passe ce que ce que
mathieu dans le reportage avait souligné
toutes les fêtes privées toutes les
choses comme ça elles ont lieu de
partout ses fins dans les hôtels j'ai vu
dans des épiceries ac c'est l'éléphant
c'est clairement non marc continue à
faire la fête avec ou sans nous et ça
c'est difficile
pour les chefs d'entreprise que nous
sommes de comprendre ses décisions on
s'attend à ce que demandent conseil de
défense sanitaire le gouvernement dort
cole quinze jours trois semaines de
fermeture en plus avec bien sûr
interdictions de consommation debout et
de danse dans les bars on sait que cette
interdiction n'est pas respectée on le
voit tous les week-ends
l'état ne fait rien
peut-être qu'ils veulent la paix sociale
c'est peut-être ça
aujourd'hui nous on est durement
impactée on souffre si on ne garantit
une ouverture dans quinze jours trois
semaines mais une vraie ouverture par
tiens vous ouvrez parce que l'été arrive
et vous fermerez l'été prochain la fin
de l'hiver prochain
on peut l'entendre
il faut que tout le monde soit logé à la
même enseigne il faut que tout le monde
soit traité de la même manière on n'est
pas des sous chefs d'entreprise on est
chef d'entreprise comme les autres on
est je pense très très important pour la
jeunesse elles ont besoin de ça ils font
la fête dans des milieux qui sont
encadrés sécurisé je rappelle quand même
qu'il ya une étude l'étude itoc qui a
été réalisée fin octobre qui soulignent
le fait d été réalisé dans les
conditions réelles un pas comme
certaines études qui demande aux gens où
ils pensent avoir été contaminées pour
moi ça c'est pas une étude je veux dire
le virus c'est pas une morsure de
serpent c'est quelque chose on se rend
compte qu'on a été contaminé 3 4 jours
après en quatre jours on a fait
tellement de choses c'est quand même
difficile de savoir en revanche l'étude
itoc elle l a pris deux groupes un
groupe témoin qui est resté
à la maison bien sagement et un groupe
qui est allé faire la fête dans une
discothèque parisienne
sans masque sans distanciation sociale
et on se rend compte que le résultat de
cette étude montrent qu'il ya pas de
surcontamination entre les gens qui ont
participé à la soirée s'en distancier
sens social et sans masque et les gens
qui sont restés chez eux qui sont les
plus loin dans cette étude ils ont aussi
comparé l par rapport à la population
parisienne au moment de l'étude
et là non plus il n'ya pas
surcontamination donc que le
gouvernement prenne des décisions soit
mais depuis le début on le clame des
études et des données scientifiques et
quand elles sortent
ilan et moi c'est vrai qu'on a entendu
ce message et on voulait savoir en tout
cas où on est et l'est discothèque on a
eu notre réponse merci beaucoup monsieur
fontaine terry et à très bientôt pour un
autre témoignage alors très bientôt donc
deux ans de pandémiques ovide et des
protocoles sanitaires qui change dans
tous les sens une campagne de
vaccination massive qui ne ferait pas
pour autant la dissémination du virus
dans le pays ça devient chiant comme le
disait mathieu lebrun dans notre
reportage dont la question de notre
débat ce soir qu vide les français
sont-ils résigné ce qui est tout de
suite pour le débat
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler vincent
banet dix conseillers l'air à la mairie
de paris soutien de valérie pécresse
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau en direct
par sky peuvent prendre quatre boeufs
délégué départemental du modem dans le
nord bonsoir france qu'aux autres boeufs
merci d'être avec nous on viens de
l'entendre la lassitude et des patrons
de discothèques et apparemment ça ne
s'arrange pas vraiment ils ne sont pas
les seuls les français sont au bord de
la crise de nerfs regarder ce sondage
réalisé par qapa.fr si un vice de
recrutement en ligne trois chiffres à
retenir 67% des français ne supportent
plus les protocoles sanitaires
88% ont du mal avec les annonces du
gouvernement et 62 % avouent avoir peur
de craquer en 2022 si la crise sanitaire
continue de s'amplifier en france 80
quand vous voyez ces chiffres vous vous
dites quoi les français sont au bord du
burn out et il faut peut-être arrêter
ces protocoles en cascade qui apporte du
stress même parfois peut-être insidieux
et bien écoutez je vais commencer en
vous répondant par cité deux noms qui me
tiennent à coeur ma fille charlotte qui
nous regardera peut-être qui en ce
moment à le coronavirus aimons mais
s'inquiète un ami d'enfance le docteur
frédéric fritsch médecin urgentiste qui
a le corps n'est venu et j'ai changé
avec lui tout à l'heure notamment pour
préparer notre échange je lui disais
alors est ce que tu es décourager est-ce
que tu baissent les bras et il me disait
non il faut que nous nous accrochions et
quoi qu'on en dise le vaccin protège
contre les formes graves et quoi qu'on
dise aussi lorsque finalement tous les
français auront eu grosso modo le
coronavirus pas trop gravement on
l'espère grâce au vaccin et bien il y
aura une forme d'immunité collective
donc je comprends la lassitude je
comprends la désespérance est tout à
fait respectable et et chacune et chacun
d'entre nous en avons ras le pompon mais
il n'en reste pas moins que il faut
faire face il faut s'accrocher et puis
écouter espérant qu'on va s'en sortir
voilà c'est un peu madame michu ce soir
mais il n'y a pas de recette magique qui
a pas de recette miracle alors on va
avant de vous donner la parole vincent
vallat dit on va regarder ce premier
message télégramme un margaux margot qui
nous dit avec au micro on se dit qu'on
va tous l'avoir un jour ou l'autre on
est tous un petit peu résigné c'est vrai
que on aussi entre voilà parfois des
moral déprimé des gens carrément énervé
on le sent parfois aussi dans les rues
des grandes villes peut-être même plus
petit c'est quoi ces ces protocoles en
cascade on n'en peut plus pousser la
faute tout simplement au virus passé les
deux je pense que déjà il n'y a pas de
fin effectivement le fait d'avoir ce
virus nous met dans une atmosphère
anxiogène
maintenant gelé protocole le souci c'est
pas tant sur le fond parce qu'on est
pour la vaccination mais sur la forme
combien on a eu le protocole je vais pas
rappeler les masques les histoires de
masse dans des rues ou autre je rappelle
aussi que c'est laid mairie locale les
régions qui ont aussi pris le parti de
ces vaccinations de cette distribution
de masques le souci c'est que les
protocoles pour venir au protocole les
protocoles ne sont plus du tout clair on
a des protocoles montjoie par exemple un
pari des protocoles qui tombe la veille
dans les écoles qui sont complètement
inapplicable et je vais vous donner un
autre exemple parce que là tout à
l'heure
monsieur par led effectivement de
famille par exemple dans une crèche les
protocoles sanitaires ont ils mis en
place très tardivement et on sait que
pourtant le virus circule chez les
enfants alors pourquoi encore une fois
c'est une impréparation du gouvernement
c'est très dommage
trente trois baffes en espagne on dit
maintenant on veut vivre avec le virus
comme si c'était une grippe on a vu de
boris johnson peut-être pour des raisons
qui peut politique et on l'a vu ce soir
lève les restrictions alors c'est vrai
que le virus marque le pas là bas
pourquoi cette notion n'est pas si
évidente en france ou au contraire on
force le pas avec le pinceau vaccinale
qui a été votée est ce qu'on devrait
penser au contraire à lever certaines
restrictions qui ne sont peut-être plus
toujours comprise
mais je pense que le pass vaccinale
s'éteint c'est un outil protée et je
fais crédit au gouvernement peut être le
suivant de la majorité mais aussi parce
que je fais vraiment crédit au
gouvernement de ne pas sûr utiliser cet
outil c'est à dire que qui nous dit que
malheureusement il y aura demain un
nouveau variant qui serait plus
dangereux donc l'idée c'est d'avoir sait
qui de l'utiliser s'il est nécessaire et
nous l'espérons tous de lever rapidement
les contraintes dès que la situation
s'améliorera et nous avons vu notamment
l'année dernière qu'elle avait tendance
à s'améliorer avec le beau temps donc
espérons qu effectivement au delà des
variants divers espérons qu'avec le
printemps les choses iront mieux mais
l'idée c'est pouvoir anticiper c'est
vrai qu'il ya souvent des mesures
d'urgence c'est vrai qu'elles sont
difficiles à comprendre et à suivre mais
je crois que chacun fait comme il veut
comme il peut et comme disait mon
contradicteur c'est vrai les mairies ce
sont aussi les régions se sont dits tout
le monde essaie de contribuer les
citoyens doivent contribuer et vous
savez j'ai bien aimé ce que disait tout
à l'heure votre interlocuteur qui tient
une une boîte de nuit et qu'ils disaient
mais au fond le gouvernement ne le fait
pas pour des raisons économiques puisque
lorsqu'il y a des fêtes privées il ils
ne touchent pas de deux taxes c'est bien
la preuve que le gouvernement le fait
dans un esprit de santé publique et pas
du tout dans un esprit de comptabilité
oui mais enfin dans le même temps
101 baladi c'est vrai que c'est
malheureux c'est ce dont se plaignaient
ce patron laisse effectivement des
défaites nive et on sait très bien que
les jeunes et on peut pas tellement leur
jeter la pierre ils continuent à se voir
dans d'ailleurs c'est ce n'est pas
interdit on le précise alors que les
boîtes de nuit sont fermés est-ce qu'il
ya pas là une forme d'incompréhension et
incohérences de la part du politique du
gouvernement alors c'est pas interdit
oui et non parce que ces établissements
là ne peuvent pas en théorie à
accueillir du public ça vous avez des
normes très strictes et d'ailleurs en
location s'est souvent des locations
saisonnières ce ne serait pas fait pour
des boîtes de nuit on n'a pas aussi
d'insonorisation nécessaire donc vous
empêche chez vous de recevoir 100
personnes si votre appartement le permet
effet soir à la maison effectivement
mais il ya aussi beaucoup de fausses
boîtes de nuit qui sont en fait des
hôtels ou des logements c'est pas du
tout normal donc là le gouvernement
reste droit dans ses bottes sur la
fermeture des discothèques sur les
restaurants pareil on en parle peu mais
il ya aussi le télétravail type qui est
en train de plomber toute heure je
parlais à des restaurateurs en train de
plomber à paris des restaurateurs et
c'est un vrai sujet dans des quartiers
de bureaux donc je pense que le
gouvernement va devoir sans compter
pardonnez-moi les combats désormais
qu'ils vivent malins ces restaurateurs
oui tous totalement et je dirais enfin
heureusement qu'il ya eu le sénat et la
commission mixte paritaire pour aussi
revoir certaines choses puisque
l'assemblée était est assez loin aller
assez loin sur les jeunes de moins de 18
ans heureusement que le sénat était
l'appareil sur sur les contrôles
d'identité c'est pas au restaurateur de
faire les contrôles d'identité donc ces
deux exemples concrets qui montrent
aussi que l'assemblée et le parlement et
que l'opposition sert à quelque chose
france 4 baffe évidemment c votre
gouvernement puisque vous êtes soutire
de la reine au modem enfin on aurait pu
éviter quand même certaines incohérences
certains casse tête on a des témoignages
notamment de parents à la veille d'une
nouvelle mobilisation
exacerbe exaspéré avec cette batterie de
tests on comprend on ne comprend plus
nous mêmes
et à peut-être par quoi je suis d'accord
avec vous des excédents le principe de
précaution et lorsqu'on fera le tri à
l'issue de sept et de cette épreuve
qu'est le coronavirus il faudra
peut-être se rendre compte que parfois
les pouvoirs publics sont sur protège
parce que malheureusement
l'américanisation de notre société fait
que tout devient pénale et parfois pour
se protéger de procédure pénale de
risques pénaux on va trop dans le
principe de précaution il faudra
retrouver je pense un principe d'
équilibre mais malheureusement vous
savez ça ne se fait pas dans l'urgence à
il faudra le faire lorsque la pandémie
sera terminée qu'on aura de nouveau la
possibilité de discuter sereinement sans
maladie vous êtes dont soutien de
valérie pécresse
vous qu'est ce que vous ferez sur ceux
du coc vide il faudra apprendre à vivre
avec lui peut-être donner plus de moyens
à l'hôpital parce que c'est ce que
disent souvent les détracteurs de ce
gouvernement il faut refonder l'hôpital
et redonner plus de moyens bah c'est ça
exactement avec valérie pécresse et
philippe juvin on a la chance d'avoir
une équipe qui connaît l'hôpital qui
connaît les soins et j'ai bien
l'impression que aujourd'hui c'est pas
le cas de ce gouvernement je rappelle
que juste un mois avant le coc vide
emmanuel macron avait été saisi par les
médecins de l'ap-hp et non des moines
pour parler de la catastrophe qui était
en train de se passer dans les hôpitaux
et puis la différence entre les
cliniques et les hôpitaux publics
s'il ya un vrai sujet il ya la médecine
d'urgence qui fonctionne très bien mais
il ya une autre médecine qui fonctionne
aussi moins bien et parce que l'hôpital
n'est plus assez aidé et soutenu dans ce
pays par les par les gouvernants et
c'est très dommage france 80 le mot de
la fin pour vous emmanuel macron en at
il assez fait pour les hôpitaux et les
systèmes de français système de santé
français pardon mais écoutez le mot de
la fin c'est que malheureusement
personne n'en avait assez fait depuis
trente ans et que le gouvernement arrive
en bout de course et paye un peu pour
tous ceux qui l'ont précédé donc mettons
nous autour de la table toutes les
forces politiques lorsque la crise sera
passée pour refonder un système
hospitalier équilibrée durable et et
redécouvrir la notion du service public
merci à vous france 80 merci aussi à
vincent maladie et c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent demain 20h pour
un nouveau numéro en attendant
l'actualité continue
[Musique]
l'afrique a été la cible de 28 millions
de cyber attaques entre janvier et août
2020 est elle devenue la nouvelle terre
de prédilection des cybercriminels nous
manquons cruellement de compétences
qualifiées en termes de cybersécurité on
estime que 96% des incidents de cyber
sécurité ne seraient pas signalés ou
resterait non résolus qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire sur un axe